because I have to start with the most
important thing first of all the movies
fantastic and you're fantastic in it
thank sure you're hearing that from
everyone do you sort of feel like you
should play the lottery soon because I
feel like you like you you have been
you've landed such great roles and been
you know what I mean like do you sort of
feel blessed right now with everything
that's been happening yeah I'm more feel
like I have you life that someone's in
the wings with the giant fly swatter
kind of waiting for you I'd like to you
know smack you down and bring you to
reality but I've been extremely lucky
with the things that I've got to do I
think that Scott's script is phenomenal
it's just so brilliant whatever I was
able to disseminate down into this into
this movie what is it like for you I
mean I know you've read a lot of scripts
what is it like for you reading
something like this for the first time
well I just was very aware the first
time I read it that it was rare I mean
not only is he taking a document that
was initially over 6,000 pages that has
been condensed to 525 pages and then
right from that a hundred and
thirtysomething page script and and
without sacrificing the humanity of a
character to make it not a book report
or a documentary of you know trying to
capture a story about obsession or
someone's he describes to me the first
time I met him as someone who has been
given the instructions to build
something and then you know turns out
that he's building his own noose which I
thought was an interesting idea he comes
DC with this you know um pride I had
optimism and almost in complete
isolation with help with other staffers
and excuse me and other people within
the CIA that were helping him you know
uncovers things that challenges his
belief in an institution that he grew up
trusting one of the things as an actor
you so much dialogue in so many words
that are not typical in like a movie
script and you shot this in 26 days yeah
what kind of challenge is that as an
actor it was 26 things was challenging
also because we were adjusting it even
as we went along in a way that was was
just challenging because he
and it's a testament to Scots script
because there's so much information we
wanted to make sure and there was more
salacious details that he could have
left out but didn't want to write a line
of dialogue that couldn't be backed up
with facts so I think every line is
footnoted somewhere I think he has the
script where everything is fact it can
be it can be backed up so even though
you those are you still have to find the
humanity in that so there was a lot of
work with even sometimes the night
before changing huge chunks to make sure
that what we're saying is not only true
but you can track the evolution of
someone starting to deteriorate a little
bit so it's a lot of you know you know
and just didn't you know absorbing and
absorbing and absorbing at it then
regurgitating it and then you have just
enough time to turn around and work on
the next thing and make sure that what
you're saying you believe I can't I
can't I can't say anything if I don't
like if I don't understand what I'm not
like if I don't understand that so you
have to kind of be doing math a lot of
not just spouting information but know
what you're saying obviously no
completely right one of the things also
about the script that I find so
interesting it's my last question is
that normally with movies they always
try to show the backstory about the
personal relationships of every
character give them more three
dimensionality but this script is all
about the stories all about the report
yeah and I find that just so fascinating
and brilliant yeah that's what I loved
about that too he was very much an
exercise of not going home with the
characters we talked about that a lot I
think at one version of the draft there
was a girlfriend or there's even a car
you know a specific car that he drove
that was you know but even then you know
sometimes we feel like some of the most
uninteresting things in movies where you
go home with them even if all the
President's Men you do go home with them
but not not often it's mostly the the
rhythms of how they investigate you know
is and through that you kind of learn
everything you need to know about the
character I think that was the idea
completely listen Congrats thank you
very much a fantastic movie thank you
very much good seeing you great seeing
you
thank you